20 avril 2010 20h56 au milieu du golfe
du mexique
la plateforme deepwater horizon
explosait 11 travailleurs de la
compagnie bp perdre la vie 780 millions
de litres de pétrole fuient durant
quatre-vingt sept jours cinq ans plus
tard les traces de ce déversement sont
encore visibles
voici les l'osha au large de la
louisiane
cet habitat naturel a été détruit par le
pétrole et voici à quoi ressemblait la
même île où des centaines d'oiseaux
venait se nourrir et se reproduire à
l'époque du désastre aujourd'hui il ne
reste plus que des coquillages et des
bouts de bois mort une île qui sera
probablement disparu l'an prochain cinq
ans plus tard constate cette
environnementalistes le golfe du mexique
souffrent toujours
l'économie de la louisiane dépend de la
bonne santé du golfe pour la pêche et le
tourisme
tout près de là sur les le grand air on
retrouve encore du pétrole
il y à un mois un tapis de pétrole durci
de 12000 kg a été découvert justice
pourtant la veille
la pétrolière bp affirmait dans cette
publicité que tout allait pour le mieux
dans le golfe
ces publicités affirme cette biologiste
m'enrage le gouvernement américain croit
que le constat de bp est inexacte et
prématurée
bp se sert dit elle uniquement des
données qui lui permettent de démontrer
que tout va bien pour les habitants de
la grande île au bout de la louisiane
les tories sont peut-être revenu mais
pas le poisson
je suis furieux déclare d une blancheur
un important distributeur de crevettes
selon lui le pétrole est toujours au
fond et les crevettes ont fui vers des
eaux plus propres
je perds 20 millions de dollars tous les
ans la pêche a grandi il dit il ne
rapporte plus qu'un million kilos de
crevettes par année six fois moins
qu'avant la catastrophe
certains crevettiers s'en tirent mieux
que d'autres ward kenshin qui vit sur
son bateau est un tueur là le
déversement ne m'a pas beaucoup touché
je suis allé pêcher plus au nord plus à
l'est
ce que d'autres n'ont pas fait certains
pêcheurs ont même quitté le métier pour
en brousse besson 81 ans qui patrouille
le petit port de grande île
la vie n'est plus pareil ici des
pêcheurs qu'elle pût les pêcheurs il
travaille pour les copains et de
l'acheteur et gens intelligents il fait
chaud plus la pêche est ce qu ils
peuvent pas faire une bonne vie bp a
beau avoir versé 20 milliards en
compensation nettoyage et restauration
les habitants sont toujours en deuil de
leur nature et de leurs ressources
j'en reviens pas je crois que ça on
vient ouais peut-être peut-être que pas
ce qu'on attend
ici christian latreille radio-canada a
grandi en louisiane